et je suis donc avec jean michel
fourgous président réélu à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines bonjour vous
avez donc été réélu lors de cette séance
d'installation du conseil communautaire
ce samedi 11 juillet dans quel état
d'esprit abordez vous ces ce nouveau
mandat ces six prochaines années
et bien déjà
dans un message avec une ambiance un
état d'esprit je dirais de rassemblement
de tout
de tous les élus on sent quand même 1 1
même une évolution et toute une histoire
c'est cette agglomération qui monte en
puissance
bon aujourd'hui est clair qu'il ya un
lien
un état d'esprit beaucoup plus fort
beaucoup plus uni
j'ai encore perfectible et ça c'est
rassurant surtout pour affronter demain
des éléments qui sont nouveaux qui sont
inédits après une crise sanitaire
économique qui arrive sociale
effectivement c'est rassurant c'est un
gros bateau on l'a dit saint quentin en
yvelines
on sait qu'on va prendre un
en
entre force 5 fort suite et peut-être au
dessus il faut pas le pied marin ils ont
montré on se connaît on commence à se
connaître travail de plus en plus
ensemble tous ensemble et c'est
rassurant d'avoir un équipage
quelle expérience et puis quelqu'un est
ce une bonne état d'esprit pour tous les
administrés de 50 ans et un équipage de
varier c'était votre souhait en 2017
lors de votre élection d'ouvrir au les
vice-présidents sommaire aussi des élus
de les maires de gauche pardon là c'est
important de renouveler ce travail ce
travail commun vous savez au delà d'être
de gauche à droite moi je fais ce qui
marche ça a marché sur le mandat
précédent d'ouvrir m'a écouté j'ai même
ouvert un peu plus parce que les
délégations queneau
aux amis l'opposition sont encore plus
importantes que la dernière fois donc
voilà on fait je crois que c'est comme
ça se construit aussi la confiance et la
qualité du travail
donc voila moi je suis très confiant
tout cas et les messages de très
sympathique qui m'ont aussi adressé en
dehors soyez des change pas et cms
maintenant cesser tout ça c'est bon pour
saint quentin c'est bon pour pour les
35000 personnes qui vivent à saint
quentin alors que ceux qui travaillent
c'est très bon signe parce que il va
falloir être réactif
voilà décider vite comme ils l'ont fait
d'ailleurs pendant la crise du coc vide
ils ont été assez exceptionnelle donc
voilà à force de se connaître vous savez
en s'estimant on désamorce les images
les caricatures qui peuvent être faite
entre les adversaires politiques dont je
trouve voilà je suis très heureux de
prendre quelques jours là parce que je
veux j'ai ramé depuis cinquante deux
mois puis je remercie aussi nos amis du
du du conseil régional et un décret c'
est du département me souviens qu'on qui
jouent aujourd'hui un rôle très
important pour consolider saint quentin
comme commun des pépites comme le dit
monsieur bédié une des pépites de falla
pépite femmes ont peu importe une des
pépites wade du département à la pour
pour faire monter pour être l'un des
modèles en france de 2,2 de la recherche
et du développement de l'intelligence de
j'irai de tous tous les grands enjeux et
puis de cette université paris saclay
qui monte en puissance ça faisait un
moment qu'on le disait mais là là depuis
quelques jours le classement
mathématiques et quand même une
indiscipline vérifiées n'aurait plus
scientifique numéro un mondial vous
m'auriez dit ça je ne vous aurais pas
cru
parce qu'on avait du mal à passer dans
le top 20 de shanghai tout d'un coup sûr
là les mathématiques on se retrouve
premier devant 4000 l'université dans le
monde attendait ses épices et c'est
toute la culture numérique que vous avez
derrière donc c'est quand même lui qui
depuis sans changer le monde aujourd'hui
c'est certainement j'ai eu beaucoup de
bonnes nouvelles si en ce moment à part
ce qu évident
mais
ça donne confiance ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui
on n'avait pas de candidat d'opposition
écoutez c'est un signe aussi
beaucoup de bonnes choses se sont
exprimés
à part les petits problèmes de niveau
d'après une technique avec ses nouvelles
wissem de vote mais non non non on est
tous très contents et on s'est tous
félicités
opposition et majorité c'est bon signe
ça les grands dossiers forcément sur sur
ces six prochaines années on a envie de
penser tout de suite aux jo c'est
bientôt les géôles à l'agglomération se
prépare attend avec impatience ses jeux
olympiques c'est déjà parti c'est qu'il
ya eu ce petit
c'est une concurrence avec chamonix x
mais on a gagné a priori entre
chamanique non c'est bien quatre sites à
monsieur déjà commencé essayez déjà à
des jeux si je vous rappelle quelques
travaux qui sont ici effectivement c'est
en ce vélodrome qui accueillera les
épreuves de cyclisme sur piste
il ya eu beaucoup de travaux sur lui ni
de loisir puisque c'est au coeur de deux
des trois sites olympiques colline bmx
et puis vélodrome mais il ya des études
qui travaillent et qui sont faites en ce
moment pour préparer le plus beau l
événement au monde
il faut quand même le dire on est
d'abord très flatté que saint quentin
on a eu nos atouts nous et attribue 4
sites olympiques
dire qu'on a montré avec la ryder cup
qu'on savait montre augmenter d
événement de dimension mondiale
donc voilà mais tout ça et puis vous
avez on a quand même les plus belles
boîtes ce résultat sur universités pour
les étudiants mais vous avez tout le
mode et l'étudiant qui monte en
puissance
le numérique a beaucoup aidés
à saint quentin on était cité en exemple
comme des agglos quinon qui a mieux tenu
dans ces crises
des supports éducatifs parce
qu'effectivement il y avait plus
monsieur encore perfectible mais bien
sûr qu'il ya eu un suivi de scolarité
qui a été bien sûr nettement meilleur
grâce à cette culture numérique donc il
faut là il faut continuer à être poussé
bien trop des cultures numériques et
aussi des enjeux on a envie de penser au
développement durable aux transports ça
ça va aussi animé il ya cette ligne 18
qui est toujours en préparation et qui
est prévue en 2030 je crois à 50 ans
divine ça ça se poursuit ses projets
également la ligne 18 les voix douce
avec les vélos fortement demandés
surtout avec trois scènes les lotois
sont les jeux olympiques bon pied de
nouvelles pistes cyclables à savoir et
ce jusque là bas
les bus électriques j'en passe ya
beaucoup depuis la voiture autonome qui
va arriver parce que y en a une partie
fabriqué à saint quentin donc voilà donc
on va certainement avoir les bénéfices
beaucoup plus vite
en matière de transport merci jean
michel phobos et le rappelle vous avez
été réélu ce matin ce samedi 11 juillet
président de saint quentin en yvelines
un nouveau mandat de six ans à la tête
de l'agglomération